urbanisation et nature le site de terres
patata macouba recèle de nombreux
secrets sur les civilisations
précolombiennes jusqu'ici dans la
commune on relevait pour seule trace de
ses anciens habitants
la fameuse roche abonde j'ai découverte
au hasard de la construction d'un chemin
traversant la ravine c'est quelque chose
qui a servi aux amérindiens à polir leur
hache en pierre
il n'avait pas de métal et donc pour
faire des haches et gisait soit la
pierre soit du lobby et il le tailler et
puis après il fallait le rendre lisse et
surtout filer le tranchant et pour cela
il venait le frottez longuement pendant
des dizaines d'heures dans ces trous en
fait c'est l'usure de ce travail qui a
fessé trouve à peine 200 mètres plus
loin se termine donc le tout premier
chantier de fouilles archéologiques de
macumba en plein milieu d'un champs de
bananes à terre patate
ces travaux sont menés dans le seul but
d'acquérir de nouvelles connaissances et
de former des étudiants ceux de la toute
première génération du cursus créé cette
année à l'université des antilles mais
aussi d'autres venant de l'hexagone
il faut que le relevé finit donc vous
pouvez retirer tous les clous et ensuite
on l'a on peut commencer à faire propre
pour confirmer de nombreux objets ont
été trouvés mais surtout de nombreuses
traces du mode de vie des amérindiens
après une première occupation du site il
y à 1600 ans il y aurait eu une éruption
de l'appeler les gens étaient sans doute
partie contre cette éruption et c'est
par un pont pays quelques décennies
peut-être en siècle avant il était déjà
parti et puis très vite après l'éruption
ils sont venus se réinstaller
ils nous on retrouve les vestiges aussi
de cette réinstallation donc ce deuxième
village est entre autres on les voit pas
ce qu'ils ont creusé des trous pour
faire d'écart b pour planter leurs
poteaux et à voix ici que la couche de
pons jeunes qu'on va très bien elle est
coupée parce qu'en fait ils ont creusé
un trou qu'on voit là dans lequel il ya
des poteries précolombiennes et qui
était pour un poteau de leur maison les
objets trouvés au cours de cette fouille
archéologique sont ensuite transportés
dans le bourg de macumba puis lavées
triées mesure est destinée
à l'exemple de ceux tranchant de haches
en pierre polie cassé mais précieux il
ya beaucoup de pièces intéressantes mais
cela les a là quelque chose de
particulier c'est qu'elle permet de
faire un lien entre le village
amérindien conflit nous et la rocha bon
vieux cons qui a servi à polir ces
haches en pierre
au total ce sont plusieurs milliers de
fragments de céramiques objets en pierre
polie ou en pierre taillée qui ont été
mises à jour
ils feront l'objet d'études minutieuses
qui viendront enrichir nos connaissances
sur les civilisations précolombiennes en
martinique